[Music]
i almost died i was away from keyboard
and thinking i was safe then i tap out
and these goddamn
phantoms oh my gosh dude i forgot em
yeah
stop just let me leave you did nothing
nothing i hate them so much
they're so dumb too you're dumb you
can't hit me
you can't fly oh my god are they worth
killing
no i'm going bad guys good start
uh good morning gamers welcome back to
minecraft hardcore
if i die i die these are the rules
i have one friend in this horrible world
and his name is
i changed his name to
he's my best friend in that right he's a
bit
what's the word without getting the
monetized not want a living
but don't worry it's safe he'll live
forever don't worry you'll live forever
in this horrible world i did a bunch of
boring stuff off camera so you won't see
a lot of differences we got a lot of
these guys now how you doing have you
liked and subscribed the hardcore all
right
so we have a lot of chiquita bonitas now
i was extremely extremely lucky i repeat
i cannot understand i
i have fortune three watch this
efficiency five
which took me forever to get in my other
world mending
you you're useless i'll kill you later
loading three
and unbreaking three that's all i need
that's all i need right what are these
useless okay on you feather falling oh
sweet do i have that
i should probably get that next yeah the
problem is my level is so low
that i haven't actually done anything i
just put
mending fortune and unbreaking on my
pickaxe and
efficiency god damn that's a good
pickaxe now hell yeah
since i never played hardcore before i
never realized just how important it is
to have
good gear and now i actually want to
live
i don't know if cartographers are the
easiest way to make money but
considering have a desert next to me it
feels like
a done deal look we also have a woodland
explorer map now so we could
do that and i don't know i don't know
this is the life that i'm living
what up jurgen you're living life how's
it going
stop complaining my god
sheeps have a place now so i could make
more beds i don't need pigs right
i built a farm for my and it's very good
it was a bit scary
but i was afk in here for like over the
night
i don't see how i would die by being afk
but that's why when i went
and tabbed out on my computer it didn't
pause the game and i almost died
if i die at least let me die on camera
that's all i ask
uh one thing i want to do today is i
want to
spruce up my another thing a little bit
i started working on it
and then i'm like they're just gonna get
mad at me
yeah you see they're just gonna get
angry if i do too much so
let's do that the pigs would keep coming
in and i don't want them to come in and
then i accidentally don't have gold
boots or something stupid
so i put these doors on it looks sick
doesn't it look cool with the red so i
thought we'd make some windows because
we're not in the most practical biome
here at least i don't know maybe we are
i don't know enough about minecraft but
it's the prettiest biome in the nether i
think so it'd be cool to have some
windows to kind of like
open it up a bit i don't know if it
makes sense but i'm doing it
look at that it looks like it makes it
cozy in a weird way
i realize just how differently i play
hardcore
as opposed to because i watched some of
my older episodes of my original
minecraft series
and it's just me talking to pets 90 of
the time
which is really funny and i kind of miss
it a little bit but i can't find any
oh i have this stupid bee dude red glass
it's gonna look sick nice and modern
look at that beautiful oh my god
i could really use some netherite maybe
i'll farm some netherright
and now i can actually do it because i
have a good pickaxe oh
you know what will look cool i just
realized oh this is scary
i don't like this oh god fingers just
become sweatier in the nether
have you guys ever watched like climbing
videos on youtube fingers get sweaty
it's the same thing this is
as hardcore does that look cool i hope
it does yes
oh my god i need to remind myself of the
constant danger here you know
we'll add some lights oh that's sick
have i covered all the holes are there
any holes
no all right we're good in the beginning
i was just messing around i'm like i
don't really care
i was like i don't i spent so much time
doing stuff in these so yeah i've
literally just been playing bedrock
version on minecraft which i
highly do not recommend it's absolutely
awful i don't understand why
it exists i just wanted to play on my
couch but it's been really fun and i've
learned a lot
more about minecraft and it feels kind
of like the most
useless skill in the world to understand
there's simple nuances between different
enchantments
yep i used to play this on a run
ironically now it's unironically
i just realized i wanted to build
different floors i can't really do
all right whatever oh yeah i remember
now i got these
this will make it look cool
oh that looks sick yeah
i also have some oh god i also have some
good exciting news
tomorrow we are shooting the coco melon
video at last
there's been so much difficulties
and you'll know once the video is up why
that means kobe obviously being one of
them but i'm very excited
i look forward to that i'm just living
the life you know this is my life and
i'm living it
i'm a happy guy what can i say
i am locked out
i have all these shroom lights that i
got i don't know how to make them look
good
see that looks kind of awkward i tried
over here
it still looks weird but you know it is
what it is this is my road to the nether
castle
which i don't think i need to go to but
damn it's cool
the new nether update is just amazing it
looks so
sick so i'm lisping i don't know why uh
let's
find some netherright and then i can
level up a little bit because that's
what i need to do more than anything
i need to be level 30. oh my god
i never had efficiency 5 before i
efficiency but
cool oh god
am i pissing off any pigs i'm so
paranoid
hardcore mode gives me trust issues gold
hold on oh god do they spawn less
on java edition because i found them
everywhere on bedrock
there we go nice yeah heal my axe
oh that was fast dude nice
let's go this is one isn't it
there we go our first nether right
pivotal moment right here
it's just one isn't it all right i'll
take it i'll take it
i'm digging this way so i can use this
tunnel to go to the nether castle if i
need to
because it feels a lot safer than me
falling into lava
right but it is nauseating i'm not gonna
lie oh god that's gonna hurt
how do i
you can stop now stop it
oh my god does it ever stop jesus
very cool let's let's go this way
can i have this in my off hand and it
lits up oh that's that's so cool
stop i hate lava stop stop cool let's go
this way
the thing is i could just run forward
like this
but i could also run into lava which is
not epic
dare me to do it
no no i need those stop
uh here we are again mr lava yes
no is the scramble going to be a problem
yes it was
you figured it out felix you're a genius
oh
lava city is there a way to deal with
that i don't know how
we're okay i just don't touch it
i don't even care stop this [ __ ]
dude oh my god lava city
i don't have fire protection on anything
stop my god
yeah baby number two let's
go is that it just one thanks notch
thanks a lot could they be in the
ceiling
uh okay all right i understand all right
just two more we can do this i swear
that i thought i heard something oh my
god i'm so
this is like playing horror games for me
guys
the pigs are like the cops in cyberpunk
you just turn around and they're there
see how much i'm leveling up from this
case
incredible this is like nauseating to
look at there we go
oh my god you gotta be kidding me
ah that's not good could i grab the lava
with a bucket
yes i can cool
stop stop
jesus yeah baby number three
come on b2 yeah
[Music]
we're done home sweet home oh that
reminds me
that reminds me of another thing i would
really want to build like faster way for
me to get up here
it's kind of annoying having to walk
these stairs all the time up and down
yeah let's do that
but first let's check out our guard
church
the holy sanctimony the furnace church
i will cook my debris in my dining table
as one does
people who complain i didn't use
furnaces as floor uh what is this
yeah apologize apologize now
see how much we level up from that guys
okay boom boom
boom now that's a fat pickaxe dude
yes you guys are living rent free you
know
go kill something i don't know oh god
don't hit me
oh god don't can you walk away i don't
like that
so i have a lot of beef but people said
that golden carrots are actually better
so maybe oh that's definitely what i
wanted to do thank you my crime so maybe
i should just
stop take your time
oh my god maybe i should grow some
carrots i need the best of the best if
i'm gonna make it right
oh god i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry
it wasn't me don't look at me like that
you're sexy and big
can someone make a resource pack and
turn him into carlos
thank you sorry ricardo ricardo my bad
my bad ricardo
all right give me the potato this is
actually i need to put a fence here
this is like i don't know how strong
they are but i have a feeling they're
going to kill me pretty quick
if i hit them by mistake if
jacksepticeye is watching this he's
crying right now
his precious taters i know how much they
mean to him
right
okay all right chiquita bonita how are
we doing down here
uh yeah give me this thank you
okay let's build our roller coaster
system here i think that's what we need
more than anything at this point
we spent hours gathering this [ __ ]
sand and now i'm just
using it for nothing i spent hours
building this god church but now i'm
just using
things
life is cruel full of disappointment
guys never forget
with no expectations come no
disappointments
never forgetty one two three four
five one two three four
ah okay [ __ ]
i should have done it one earlier
[Music]
how do i get around i'll think about it
later if you got a problem just
solve it later that's that's the best
way to do things trust me guys
uh this is awful all right well here's
our beta version
you know what that's actually not too
bad that actually kind of works
in this really strange way i have
nowhere to walk here but whatever
whatever uh does it work down
oh amazing
oh this couldn't be more perfect okay
let's say
i want to go to the mines i click a
button
and that changes a piston so i no no
you're not going you're not going
anywhere
so it changes the piston down here i'll
have to draw a signal all the way though
and then it goes all the way to the mine
and another button that says okay i want
to go
to the fishing pond and then it or i
want to go to the portal and then it
changes another
that'd be cool i like that kind of [ __ ]
but obviously
first of all oh we gotta see if that
likes the railroad can bees writing in
uh
in minecarts i'm thinking yes or i could
just
literally just put another track that
goes out there
i guess that's the easy way to do it one
track goes to the mine
one track goes to yeah that's probably
the easiest way i don't have to [ __ ]
around with redstone
hey time to wake up let's get his honey
oh got an achievement for that all right
what can i do with honey bottle i can
make a honeycomb block
or a honey oh ooh
honey blocks would be really useful i'll
put that in the redstone
you're right you're free come with me
come with me come with me
come with me come with me come with me
oh oh come on i can't
keep fighting you hey you're gonna go in
there roller coaster you're gonna love
it
trust me it's safe nothing bad is ever
oh my god oh my god just come
is the door too thick you're too thick
for the door no you're fine oh look at
you you're so cute
come here come here come here come here
god damn oh my god
what a beach yes
don't [ __ ] with me all right now go here
he loves it
you can fly you know that right you fly
over the fence
thank you there we go here we go here we
go all right guys
this is his first time so be nice to him
all right don't worry
they laugh because they're jealous and
they pretend like they're better and
but no one that laughs at other people
is better than
anyone you hear that people who judge
others
do so only to feel better about
themselves but people who are strong
independent competent and beautiful
like you we don't care now get in the
boat i mean uh
get in no you need to i need you to i
need you to go in it
oh my god it's working
[Music]
yeah you did it
well done oh you're going back
again he oh he went into the void
he loves it yeah i was laughing now
chumps
you're too fat to getting one now how do
i get you out of that
all right don't worry don't worry hang
tight i'm gonna get help
where's my fishing run don't worry i got
you
i'ma pull you out nice and safe so i
don't hurt you all right
this looks like you're a little stuck
there buddy oh my god wait there's a way
to see the block
it's like ctrl shift b or something is
it b
narrator narrates chat what hello
pewdiepie underscore epic says hello oh
my god this means i can talk to the p
pewdiepie underscore epic says b says
get me out by yeah
sorry now we know how to
how to pronounce your name pewdiepie
underscore epic says bfftpp
all right pewdiepie underscore epic says
bbb
that makes sense he is a bee all right
let's just be careful
yes you're free don't escape do not
escape this is not your chance to escape
get it come back here
uh oh that's right i remember seeing a a
bee
in the desert right maybe we should go
and get it so we can have many people
that'd be sick right right all right you
know where you live you know where you
live and it's not in the wall
go go left go left my dude please
you have the iq of a goddamn bee for
some
do not escape i'm gonna give you some
action all right
i'm gonna get you some i know you're
lonely don't worry
crafting thank you thank you game
crafting uh i know i am aware how do i
turn that off now god damn it
so wait can these guys are they actually
too fat or can they actually go in one
go in go in my dude trust me
they're too fat they must be too fat can
i put a leash on you are you gonna hurt
me
my god i can put a leash on them that's
[ __ ] up
[Music]
that's so weird uh something yes i know
yeah you're my uh you're my uh servant
that's what i was gonna say
you're my servant follow me listen up
can i bring you to the nether
can you like shut up in the nether for
me yeah yeah follow me
servant trust me this is gonna be
awesome we're gonna have fun
trust stop resisting we're gonna have
fun i don't understand why they never
listen to me all right
i might have to cut into this a little
bit
come on yes he went nice all right kill
listen up we're going to kill is it too
big
kill him oh my god yeah [ __ ] him up
hell yeah oh you don't look too good are
you okay
oh this is amazing i can just keep you
here like my littlest crafting
servant kill him i don't like them they
always come in my house
oh there we go yes perfect this is the
test of
skill two hogling three hog links dude
all right you go you go my dude
you're free you're free no no no no no
don't [ __ ] out on me dude
are you not doing it you have to do
something
i am oh sh oh god
oh god they're gonna oh oh he's oh he's
wrecking oh my god left and right
oh yes dude you're awesome
keep doing that keep doing your thing
man crafting
i know yeah
servant go
dude i'm bringing you everywhere crap
you're amazing
all right dude let's go back what's your
name
dimitri di meteria come here
crafting oh my god it's so annoying all
right dimitri
look at me you're with me now you
understand
crafting large chest oh i like the sound
of that
don't you don't you like that too
dimitri i bet you do you honky bastard
all right you look cool you look real
good oh it's so tempting to make him
fall
god forgive me dimitri
it was it was a prank this is a prank
dude i wasn't gonna do it large chest
i know i like it was just a prank bro
come on
i would never hurt the meteorite it's my
favorite chest i know it's a goddamn
large chest
i made the large chest it's my large
chest all right
see you later man
what's that where did dimitri go uh he's
just chilling
he's fine don't worry about it don't
worry about it all right let's get some
more gamer bread oh they're asleep
large chest it's make yeah it makes me
laugh rabbiting
search items edit box search items edit
box
break up gamer cartographer button
narrator off thank you oh my gosh
chiquita bonita you always sleep with
your eyes open cheeky tabonita
i know there was a spawner if you guys
remember on the very first episode there
was a spider spawner somewhere
i want to find it again oh my god it's
actually worth picking stuff up now
oh there it is i didn't make my mind so
fast i don't even notice
oh yes give me give me give me give me
oh my god no no yes
oh it's only nope here we go
nice oh what's that
eight i'll take it
oh my god that gave me a heart
i forgot about that jesus hey gravel
gravel revenge die
oh my god right away hell yeah
17 let's go
so i basically have a forever pickaxe
now that's super good
i've been playing minecraft wrong all
this time there's so much stuff
i could have done oh i don't like that
why y'all [ __ ] there ah what
you doing
i saw you come out where'd he go
oh my god that's so spoopy come back oh
god
oh no this is not a survival horror game
oh my god where did he go oh my god
my mind blown
yes i might gravel with another right
pickaxe
oh my it could have been a creeper
where where did [ __ ] come from
i see you [ __ ] why are you
spawning there
[ __ ] oh my god
stop where are they spawning from
they probably like this little corner
don't they
there you are you stinker oh wait
[Laughter]
die die god damn it
well you should have you should have
died
not on my watch [ __ ] oh my god they're
coming from
i'm here hello
[ __ ] oh jesus
i don't have the nerfs man i'm the
coward i'm a little scared i'm not gonna
lie
guys but i said i wouldn't go up before
level 30 so that's what we're doing
oh i see you
oh my god you creepy son of a
oh they disappear in water don't they
see i know minecraft i learned
ah
[Music]
oh god it's scary oh nice we got another
one sweet
ah there's two that is dangerous
that's what a coward would say of course
of course
nothing is dangerous if you're swedish
and handsome i joke about being handsome
and then
i realize it seems like i'm gloating now
and me saying that
by the way guys the official source in
the world
said it uh oh here's trouble
oh mother [ __ ]
goddamn gang bang here blow hello
yeah oh yeah that's what i say if i see
a creeper
there it is that's my cue to get out
am i on the water yes
yes i am oh it's daytime yes
whoa that's kind of trippy all right
this is definitely not where the spider
cave is the spider case is on that side
all right that's good to know
home sweet home baby yeah
chiquita bonita how you doing you having
a lot of
being bound chicken wow now i can just
ride my
i could just walk up which is what i
wanted oh there you are
i'm suffering from success here guys i
throw away money yeah i don't care
yeah uh yeah that's what i oh my god
see how much faster that was all right
successful
mining i'd say the least we could burn
down this entire island with this coal
i'm gonna make myself some boots give me
something good blast protection
deathstrider sweet that's what i wanted
now i just gotta
hell yeah this is going great i need a
book and i need my money
my money there we are i don't even need
my money
let's put feather falling four on those
and now we got ours oh i gotta put
mending on number two now we got
ourselves
some goddamn good boots hell yeah so
apparently vegans who throw it
through a fit and they said that the
better food is not
beef the better food is golden carrots
this sounds like a mr peace video this
is what i eat now
damn we went from poor to rich real fast
look at that [ __ ]
just gotta improve this one and this one
put netherride on them
but get a better sword and we're sorted
eight carrots now gamers that's it for
this episode
hardcore minecraft it's very different
but it's really fun
it's very exciting hope you guys enjoyed
this series if you do
show support smash like that was my
whatsapp and i see you guys
oh wait i gotta do it like this i don't
have face game and i see you guys
in the next episode yeah bro face